look what you can win an adventure
you got all kinds of things on this
thing man how can you go wrong with a
lunchable hey what a dude gq it's your
boy ski master slump guy these are my 10
essentials
and welcome to my lifestyle you dig
[Music]
yes indeed
the millennium puzzle
this is the um the chain that yugioh had
on the actual chain that yugioh had on
this was like a tribute piece kind of me
and juice world was talking about him
getting this piece in general and since
he wasn't able to do it i just decided
to do it myself and it's also like a
really big thing of my childhood like
yu-gi-oh was a really big thing in my
childhood i never used to have cable so
i used to watch like cbs and i had to
wait the saturday mornings for it to
come on and like i used to dream about
waking up and watching that so yeah
definitely
yu-gi-oh peace
you dig me
what's funny about the do-rag is usually
people tie it to the back right it's
something that i started so long ago bro
i didn't like i just looked so i looked
like a [ __ ] men in black alien with
it tied to the back i felt like so i was
just like okay i'm gonna tie it to the
front i just was experimenting first i
had it like directly in the middle of my
head i had it like i tried it all kind
of ways and then i just tied it like
with a knot to the front like a shoelace
and it just stuck you know what i mean
and it i don't know for some reason it
was just iconic after that everybody's
just like okay that's a new way to tie
the durag so we'll incorporate it too
you know what i mean so it's crazy how
like the durag how far it's
come for me i want to have one of those
do-rag lines where i'm just sitting with
an awkward picture on the front like in
in some side of like a beauty supply
store or something you see me like
touching my head like
[Music]
why i say this is an essential for me is
because drip you feel me like i'm one
person
that's really big on clothes and how i
dress or what i'm wearing you know what
i mean so this was just basically to add
like clothing and drip into it and i
usually always have a fitted hat not a
snapback not one of the [ __ ]
grip your head grip your head tight as
hell hats i always like fitteds i i do
kind of with the dad hats as well and i
look with the trucker hats as well but
um usually my favorite hat will be
definitely the fitting hat so definitely
the essential
wow i got my [ __ ] cellular device i
handle all my like everything on here
and i'm horrible with my phone on top of
that but one thing i do want to say that
i have to add on top of the cellular
device as an essential is the otterbox
right
boy oh boy am i horrible i'm so clumsy
like i don't know what it is like i
dropped my phone at least been through
like in the past years so i've been
through like three
three or four phones honestly if i'm
being honest and i just got this phone
refixed i fixed the lcd screen out here
just the other day so my favorite apps
to use are definitely um apple music
soundcloud spotify
um
netflix i'm really big netflix and i'm a
really big crunchy role when i'm out
traveling i have to get my anime in bro
i have to so crunchyroll i have two
year-long accounts on
crunchyroll and funimation i'm a wii
most likely so yeah
my favorite animes right now would have
to be black clover demon slayer the
early seasons of attack on titan
um i like promise neverland right now
jiu-jitsu kaizen is kind of going crazy
right now
there's a lot of animes that i get that
i that i like man
a lot so it's hard to name just a few
this is something that us jamaicans call
leaf you can use fronto you can use
trees wrap but this is called grab a
leaf and um we use it to smoke like
smoke spliffs if you ever smoked spliff
is basically like a weed with this leaf
which is basically kind of like a
tobacco leaf you crush it in there or
you just add it into whatever you're
smoking and you call it a spliff man
sometimes i'll be having to go on a hunt
or usually i have to bring them with me
wherever i'm going so out here i got
kind of lucky they have them at the
smoke shops out here in la where i where
i'm from more they're they're more
sold like down south like where i'm from
from florida so that's where i started
smoking grabba leaf so it's all over the
stores in florida atlanta and more south
but when you get up north or out here
near west it's like kind of
you gotta find it a lot of jamaicans or
islanders smoke like this but i
definitely do
i'm jamaican myself my both of my
parents that you're making so it's
probably really what i get it from
grab a leaf ting
grab a leaf ting dog oh you mean dog
hey bix
yes the bix no no no not the the scrawny
um weak looking lighters that we be
getting that be stressing our fingers
out the bigs bro i gotta have this also
because i smoke new ports and i smoke
grabber like i showed you so gotta have
the lighter with it you know what i mean
um
plus i gotta have a pack of it because
you know professional thieves out here
it's like assassin's creed out here with
these lighters so
gotta have a pack of meaties
i'm a really big person on like uh
intention or energy so i feel like if
you personally believe that that white
lighter is bad luck then you believe in
that negativity will bring the bad luck
to you you know what i mean so
gotta have these
even if it's not airpods i'm usually i'm
usually rocking some type of uh
headphones with me usually i have the
big headphones that go over my ears
because that's how i usually like to
listen to music especially with
traveling and being on the plane and
having the noise cancellation so airpods
is always a really big essential for me
i'm always listening to music always
always listening to erica badou grimes
some beautiful nostalgia
yeah so while i'm going throughout my
day i'll probably just right through my
if i have something fire that i have in
my head i'll just open my notes and
write it down even if it doesn't go to a
beat so far and somehow i would squeeze
that into a fire ass beat that i like i
would find some way to put it into a
fire as beat i would find some type of
flow that i could fit it and then i
would just fit that into there keyboard
and mouse i am a video game freak i play
all kinds of games and i just started
getting into more of uh keyboard and
mouse gaming i'm really into
call of duty rust apex legends all kinds
of crazy runescape was like the first
game i used with keyboard and mouse it
was definitely tough for me to figure
out the controls because
i haven't really used the keyboard and
mouse and like since i was like younger
when i was in school it doesn't have to
be it doesn't even have to be a logitech
it could be any kind of keyboard or
mouse or even an xbox 360 controller as
soon as i'm done with this interview
with you guys i'm about to bust this
thing open and play some video games
with it boom bang bao what you mean huh
huh
you know you've seen these come on now
son
you can't tell me this is not an
essential at some point in your life
they even got the little they got the
bev not only do you got the food you got
the bed you need the bev so i mean i can
slap these at any time of day lunch
breakfast dinner it really don't matter
so
these these specifically are the cracker
ones you know what i mean i mean i
really get i can i can get into it all i
get freaky get to get the nachos get the
pizza you feel me make a crazy little
pizza slap that tomato sauce on there i
mean lunchables is goated so i had to
add it for sure wow get a close-up on
that pedialyte you did
you got to get the nutrition facts on
there gee
i go out i drink i be waking up feeling
like i got beat up by a poltergeist or
something like a ghost or something when
i drink this i wake up feeling good
my muscles are relaxed you know what i
mean i could i could go on about my day
after a long night of drinking so
pedialyte important important i thought
it was just for babies too and it's
crazy i i just got put on to pedialyte
at least last year at least last year
you know what i mean and what's crazy is
i was like what am i stupid i could have
been doing this i used to be drinking
gatorades and stuff like that hot warm
gatorades but this is definitely better
definitely better to replace those
electrolytes get you a pedialyte you
feel me
boom gotta have this i mean like if this
was out the wrapping i would have turned
it on for y'all let it vibrate for you a
little bit we could have gotten even
more freaky so
for me i've never really had um braces
or anything like that and i don't have
um veneers either so i really gotta be
taking care of my teeth i drink brown
liquid the majority of the time and
stuff too so hey i ain't gonna lie i
have to hit the dentist for him to tell
me like yeah dude you need to start
flossing more okay he was like you gotta
floss cause he smoked weed and i was
like yeah all right my floss game has
been impeccable lately i'm not gonna lie
and it's usually always a um mechanical
toothbrush i don't know why i just be
feeling fancy with these [ __ ]
i'm not gonna lie
hey thank you guys for coming and
checking out my 10 essentials
i hope that you can relate to my
lifestyle
and uh until next time